hello luca hi c
luca
from denmark
you've been with us uh for a little
while now and you are looking after our
marketing and communications but also
you have been learning spanish i have
yeah you're doing a 90-day challenge i
am i've been at it for a month tomorrow
a month tomorrow a month is 30 days
right
yeah all right so here we have we took
the trouble of printing out the progress
snapshot
i think i'm doing well well i think so
you know the certainly the known words
total exceeds your target
the uh but the big number to me is links
you've created 1100
almost 1200 links which is like
three times
your target how many am i supposed to
well 400 390 right yeah so almost 1200
and to me that's the most important
indicator if you're creating links that
means you're you're looking at words
you're trying to notice things and
you're also covering a lot of a lot of
content yeah links learned to me is less
important because eventually you'll
you'll learn them so that's that's
something that comes kind of almost
incidentally plus you do i gather you're
not listing all your listening very
often this listing number is not
accurate because you're not able to and
the other one is your words of reading
you've read 11 000 words so here again
you know that's like uh you know more
than four times your target so very good
thank you
very good
how are you how are you finding it i i
really like it um last week i wrote
about using flashcards and all those
little tests and
and i really enjoyed that i feel like
i'm learning a lot from that and
and i think these are just to interrupt
these are the we have five different is
it four or five different four different
ways of reviewing uh the words and
phrases that you've saved yeah yeah and
i think that's fun because it's kind of
like a game right so like you know i get
a little bit bored of reading and
listening okay and then i i think that's
fun and and then i go back to reading
and listening and then i've picked up
more i think in the media you know
this is the thing variety makes
everything more fun right i think that's
what it is yeah absolutely and i think
particularly too at the beginning
that i think flashcards like that are
particularly helpful yeah because you're
reviewing these words everything is so
strange to you
later on when you become more
comfortable in the language you'll be
happier just listening and reading yeah
especially so i like the uh the
repetition of it you see the flash cards
sort of more than once right and in the
end you actually start to understand a
little bit absolutely and then when you
go back to the to the text yes then
you're like oh i recognize that from my
flash cards absolutely that's why i like
those that combination do you review
your flashcards before a lesson or after
a lesson or not at all connected i
actually
when i get the email every day 25 links
or something daily links right i
actually go in
the on that day
and click that and then just do that
whole session wow okay so that's
probably why i'm doing so well
how is your uh comprehension
that's sort of up and down right i have
to have good days and bad days
and when i have a good day i'm i get
very excited like yeah i understand
something but um but then there are days
so i'm like why don't i understand any
of it is that when you're reading or
when you're listening
i think
uh well i'm i'm listening to like very
beginner stuff so
it's sort of when i'm i think when i
read and listen at the same time i kind
of understand a lot of it
if i just listen
then i don't really get it
if it's any consolation to you in korean
which i've been doing now for many many
months
easy simple content i can understand
yeah but the difficult like the podcasts
if i read and listen at the same time i
understand well when i go away and i
listen without reading i don't
understand well my comprehension goes
down to about 15 wow so it just takes
time yeah it just takes time i think
that's that's the thing it's the
patience exactly i don't have much of
that but i think i'm learning to get to
know you have some more patience exactly
i was going to say you'll not only learn
spanish
learn to be patient
that's true anything else no that's
about it okay well we'll check in in a
month from now
and we'll see how things are going at
that time yeah thanks okay